[Música]
su hijo físico trabajó con la física de
este planeta un planeta que tiene una
dinámica interna muy activa que se
refleja en volcanismo terremoto etcétera
tenemos un océanos que están en
permanente movimiento tenemos una
envolvente gaseosa que es delgada pero
que es donde ocurren la mayoría de los
fenómenos del tiempo y el clima y que
vamos a hacer ver que tiene gran
importancia los geofísicos nos creíamos
el cuento de que precisamente la
geofísica la física del planeta era la
condición más importante para que
existiera la vida sobre este planeta
como la conocemos pero en los últimos 20
o 30 años hemos descubierto que la
biosfera el colectivo de todos los
organismos microorganismos fauna flora
nosotros mismos ha evolucionado con el
planeta y en ese proceso ha generado las
mismas condiciones de la vida así que
hemos tenido una dosis de humildad de
reconocer de que ésta no es solamente
una roca
cercana al sol sino que tiene una
biosfera y es la biosfera la que de
alguna manera se encarga también de
mantenerse
hoy día les voy a contar dos historias
sobre el oxígeno esta historia es más
allá de los detalles lo que quiero es
iluminar de alguna manera cuán
resiliente es la biosfera esa capacidad
que tiene cierto de recibir golpes pero
recuperarse algunas veces lo hace a
través de una adaptación más o menos
gradual y otras veces como a mover lo
hace a través de transformaciones muy
profundas pero antes de ir esas a esa
historia quería hacer una encuesta muy
pequeña sobre su opinión sobre el cambio
climático entonces voy a hacer una
afirmación de usted me dicen si están de
acuerdo
piensan que el cambio climático es uno
de los mayores problemas de la humanidad
en este siglo quienes están de acuerdo
estoy hablando los conversos
una pregunta un poquito distinta piensan
que el cambio climático es el mayor
problema que tiene chile el año 2020
[Música]
bueno como ustedes ven hay un gradiente
verdad las cosas cambian un poquito con
la cercanía y con la escala temporal y
espacial que le coloquemos pero
ciertamente el cambio climático es algo
importante y eso lo comento porque
finalmente el objetivo de mi
presentación esta tarde en cantarlo en
la medida de lo posible es tratar de que
nos fascina moss con nuestro planeta
finalmente uno no puede cuidar ni
proteger algo que no conoce y ojalá que
además lo entienda así que esa es mi
objetivo final que voy a tratar de
transmitir con estas dos historias
además esta historia nos pueden dar
alguna elección precisamente para
navegar este que de mamos de el
antropoceno o sea de la época en que la
humanidad está siendo un factor tan
importante como es precisamente la
geofísica el volcanismo y otros
fenómenos naturales así que vamos con
esta historia pero antes no nos
olvidemos de hacer algo muy importante
respiren
respiren otra vez más uno anda todo el
día respirando verdad porque será tan
importante respirar que nos da el aire
que respiramos muchas cosas pero al
poder escuchar la palabra clave es
oxígeno cierto el oxígeno no es el
alimento pero el oxígeno está en la base
de poder obtener la energía de los
alimentos de la materia orgánica que
nosotros consumimos sin oxígeno
lamentablemente nos va mal con oxígeno
nos va bien de unas 100 moléculas que
ustedes respiraron o que están
respirando continuamente hay como unas
20 moléculas de oxígeno el 21% de
oxígeno es más o menos lo que tiene la
atmósfera en la actualidad bien por
nosotros porque como les decía es muy
importante y bien por nosotros porque el
oxígeno no es un gas particularmente
abundante en el universo y si miramos la
historia la tierra la tierra tiene como
4 mil 600 millones de años de edad o sea
tiene tener una cantidad respetable de
años la mayor parte de la historia
planetaria ha sido sin oxígeno esto de
tener como les decía el 21 por ciento es
como la última novedad del año durante
la mayor parte de la historia no ha
habido oxígeno en este planeta y una
cosa interesante es que la vida surgió
en ese ambiente anaeróbico sin oxígeno
hace unos cuatro mil millones
no sabemos muy bien cómo apareció pero
apareció y tenemos evidencia muy sólida
de eso como les decía es la vida
anaeróbica sin oxígeno tomaba su energía
de los sulfuro y tenía que estar muy
cercana a ciertas fuerzas y formas
hidrotermales en las profundidades de
los océanos y así estuvieron estos
microorganismos muy simple
tranquilamente por los próximos 1.000
millones de años y repente surgió algo
muy maravilloso que son las
cianobacterias unos organismos un
poquito más complejo y que inventaron
algo maravilloso que es la fotosíntesis
en ese proceso que todo algo que lo
hemos escuchado verdad lo que uno hace
es conseguir tomar luz solar y tomar co2
dióxido de carbono y eso genera glucosa
la rica glucosa que nos permite crecer y
a las plantas les permite crecer en ese
proceso como sus productos fueron
colocando oxígeno en la atmósfera así
que teníamos una atmósfera sin oxígeno
anaeróbica que se fué oxigenando
paulatinamente debido a la acción
fotosintética de la cianobacteria todo
parece muy bien y podríamos terminar
esta historia feliz porque finalmente
con oxígeno se apareció la respiración
celular y finalmente llegamos nosotros
pero hay un elemento en este medio que
es bastante perturbador
y hace lo que tiene que hacer el oxígeno
oxida cosas y tiende a destruirlas hasta
cierto punto y de hecho cuando se empezó
a oxigenar la tierra se empezaron a
morir los microorganismos todos estos
primeros organismos anaeróbicos que
habían dominado el planeta
desaparecieron casi por completo y las
cosas se van a colocar un poco peor
porque el oxígeno también en la
atmósfera una vez que finalmente llegó a
ese nivel empezó a reaccionar con otros
gases y enfrío el planeta tierra que era
bastante cálido lo llevó casi una
condición de bola de nieve o sea todo
cubierto por hielo y el hielo también no
es una cosa que sea particularmente
buena parada para la vida así que no
solamente se movieron las bacterias
anaeróbicas también se empezaron a morir
la la cianobacteria así que estamos en
un grave problema en este intento de
oxigenar la tierra que finalmente nos
parece bien casi eliminamos toda la toda
la vida porque el oxígeno como les decía
era tóxico o es tóxico para esas
bacterias anaeróbicas y enfrío el
planeta
afortunadamente algunos pedacitos
quedaron sin hielo y ahí la vida
continuó floreciendo se generó
precisamente este otro proceso que se
llama la respiración celular en que se
ocupa el oxígeno de manera más directa y
por lo tanto vinieron formas más
complejas con más energía uno puede
más cosas y finalmente apareció la
florida fauna como la conocemos hay un
detalle adicional interesante es que
toda la vida estaba concentrada hasta
unos 2000 incluso mil millones de años
atrás estaba concentrado en el océano
porque si alguien que pretendía salir a
los continentes llegaba los rayos
ultravioletas y los freían literalmente
verdad la radiación ultravioleta es muy
violenta con los organismos vivos y
destruye todo el tejido
el oxígeno empezó a reaccionar también
con la radiación ultravioleta y como
extra bonus se generó la famosa capa de
ozono que es la que nos protege de los
rayos ultravioleta así que esa es la
primera historia partimos de un planeta
sin oxígeno se generó el oxígeno
mediante la cianobacteria casi nos vamos
a negro porque casi desaparece toda la
vida fue la primera gran extinción en
masa pero finalmente algo bueno sucedió
ya vamos a sacar algunas consecuencias
resta de esta historia
como encuentran que está esta sala tan
bien de temperatura o no bueno estamos
así estas ricas pasadas porque tenemos
aire acondicionado del aire
acondicionado esta es otra historia así
que estamos haciendo un salto cuántico
al presente el aire acondicionado es
bastante antiguo lo inventaron como 1900
al principio de 1900 y para refrigerar
se ocupaba metano amoníaco cosas que no
suenan muy bien de hecho tan inflamable
y no era muy bueno
la inventiva humana precisamente en un
afán de mejorar eso el proceso
industrial que también servía para la
actividad doméstica inventó una molécula
una molécula artificial que se llama cfs
es clorofluorocarbono y tan todos muy
contentos con la molécula porque ayuda a
la refrigeración era inerte no
reaccionaba con nada así que era la
mostrada en las portadas la revista como
la molécula del año todos muy contentos
con los cfc eso por supuesto se producía
a nivel superficial y lentamente fue a
llegar llegando a la estratosfera y ahí
empezó a consumir el ozono se acuerdan
del ozono lo que nos protegía los rayos
ultravioleta bueno los cfc que fueron
creados con una buena intención
terminaron destruyendo el ozono y eso
produjo que llegara a más radio su
nuestra violeta al planeta tierra para
superficie del planeta de hecho la
primera evidencia que las cosas andaban
mal fue precisamente que la radiación
ultravioleta empezó a aumentar en la
antártida y cerca del polo sur y como
suele suceder con la sociedad y con las
personas lo primero que fue fue la etapa
de negación mandaba los datos de la
antártida sean nuestro tipo están viendo
más los datos no puede ser que el
ultravioleta esté aumentando así que
pasaron algunos años en que se acumuló
suficiente evidencia científica
observaciones como para mostrar que
había un problema en el funcionamiento
del sistema terrestre después vino la la
búsqueda de los culpables se desarrolló
una elegante teoría que vinculó
precisamente la pérdida del agujero de
ozono con lo que les comentaba
previamente que es los los
clorofluorocarbonos cfc de hecho el
único premio nobel que tenemos como en
ciencias de la tierra fue esa teoría que
hacía ese vínculo entre la 12 fcc y la
destrucción del ozono y bueno una vez
que entonces tuvimos la evidencia
observacional y tuvimos la teoría y la
política y la economía
hicieron su parte porque se empezaron a
hacer una serie de acuerdos
internacionales la gente se reunía eso
todo ocurrió más o menos en la década de
los 80 no lo había dicho pero la primera
evidencia que los 1 estaba en problemas
venía más o menos del año 75 así que
pasaron unos 10 años hasta que empezaron
estos acuerdos internacionales que
culminaron el año 1987 con el protocolo
de montreal y en ese acuerdo los países
se colocaron de acuerdo en no emitir más
de fcc eso ha ido ocurriendo
progresivamente prácticamente ya no hay
cfs en la atmósfera o muy poco el
agujero todavía nos acompaña se forma
todos los primavera sobre básicamente el
polo sur pero está en franca
recuperación así que en nuestra lista de
problema casi podemos decir problemas
superados no completamente pero estamos
en camino
lo que les quería decir que terminamos
con la etapa de historia pero finalmente
quería tomar un par de lecciones de lo
que hemos comentado porque hay cierta
analogía inescapable piensen en lo que
pasó con las cianobacterias unas
bacterias que sin saberlo inundaron la
atmósfera de un gas que era tóxico en
ese momento y ahora no nos parece que el
oxígeno es tóxico pero para ella y para
las otras bacterias anaeróbicas era
tóxico y prácticamente eliminó toda la
tierra afortunadamente nos salvamos por
un poquito y ese es ese salvar se logró
que la biosfera continuará floreciendo y
expandiéndose así que tenemos una
especie dominante que produjo un efecto
indeseado naturalmente inconsciente pero
no sé si ven la analogía con lo que
estamos haciendo ahora cierto de alguna
manera también hay una especie dominante
que también está emitiendo un gas
contaminante y que eventualmente puede
tener y está teniendo consecuencias que
pueden ser muy problemáticas
la otra analogía el otra historia tenía
que ver con esto el cfs y el ozono es
opuesta de alguna manera que la
tecnología todos la ocupamos de alguna
manera la tecnología
ciertamente que ayuda a la vida y ayuda
a que nos desarrollemos ya que tengamos
una mejor calidad de vida precisamente
pero en este proceso muchas veces muchas
veces cometemos errores y lo importante
es que cuando reconocemos esos errores
cuando la ciencia ve la evidencia y la
sociedad se hace cargo de ello a través
de la economía y la política global esos
errores y esos problemas se pueden
superar lo que estamos viviendo ahora y
vamos precisamente al tiempo actual es
que nuestro apetito por combustibles
fósiles para generar energía y para
tener una mejor calidad de vida
supuestamente está llenando la atmósfera
de dióxido de carbono eso incrementa el
famoso efecto invernadero lo cual por
una parte acidifica el océano con más
las consecuencias para la vida en él y
por otra parte aumenta y las
temperaturas y todos los fenómenos del
cambio climático que ustedes conocen
la pregunta es si en el futuro vamos a
hacer como las cianobacterias que no
tuvieron mucha posibilidad de hacer nada
o vamos a hacer como lo hicimos con el
ozono tal vez colocarnos de acuerdo a
nivel global y finalmente revertir el
problema y yo estoy optimista hoy día
por lo menos estoy optimista el otro día
no estaba tan optimista pero hoy día
estoy optimista con esta audiencia y
creo que todavía podemos resolver el
problema ahora para resolverlo y yo sé
que hoy día estamos hablando de la
educación yo creo que esa es la clave y
tenemos que por una parte entender y por
otra parte fascinarnos con el planeta
tierra muchas veces estos problemas se
plantean de manera de una crisis muy es
que muy
apremiante verdad y es verdad pero por
otra parte vuelvo a repetir lo que decía
el comienzo no podemos no podemos
arreglar no podemos cuidar algo si no lo
conocemos tenemos que fascinar no y
entenderlo tenemos que entrar un poquito
más en contacto con el planeta tierra
sin eso no vamos a resolver el problema
uno siempre piensa que otras personas lo
van a resolver por uno pero tenemos que
resolverlo todos todos tenemos que hacer
nuestra contribución no podemos dejar de
verlo y tampoco podemos pensar que hay
soluciones mágicas hay gente que piensa
está la solución al lado este problema
del cambio climático hay un problema
social muy complejo no es solamente
científico es un problema social porque
estamos todos involucrado en ello y por
lo tanto sin educación y sin hacer ese
cambio en la educación y en cómo nos
preparamos para el cambio
no voy a colocar en positivo si es que
nos preparamos para este cambio vamos a
lograr sobrevivir muchas gracias
nuevamente por su atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]